[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh one of our favorite guests
because he always tells us things he
makes us smarter he's daniel jeremiah
nfl network analyst you can follow him
on twitter at move the sticks also host
to the move the sticks podcast
he'll be on the main set with the big
boys tonight in cleveland
for the first round tonight starting at
8 eastern
let's start with the poll question here
give me the headline tomorrow that we'll
be talking about what the niners did
what the falcons did
where justin fields goes what the
patriots did
or a big trade where are you gonna go
i'll say uh gosh dan i'm gonna say it's
obviously gonna be quarterback related
i'll say it ends up being a trade not
for one of those first guys i think we
could get a little bit of a surprise
with three because i still don't
you know i'm still not convinced it's
mac jones but everything in i hear says
mack jones
everything in my gut says trey lance um
so i don't think that's decided yet but
i think what could end up being
the big storyline is whichever one of
those fifth quarterbacks starts to drop
a little bit
who's going to be the team that goes to
get him what team do you think would be
most in play to go after if it's trey
lance who falls or justin fields
to me i know everybody's looking at new
england i think that's a possibility
i still think washington not having
their long-term guy they've got 50 right
now but
uh trying to find that next guy to be
the long-term guy
that to me is just a logical one that
you could see them be aggressive
chicago there's the need but man they
gotta win right now
um they're in survival mode so i don't
know necessarily that that points to
them
you know making that type of a jump and
to be honest with you if i'm if i'm the
president of the bears the owner of the
bears
i'm not so sure i want a regime that's
on a little shaky ground
parting with a bunch of future picks for
my the next guys i might have to bring
in so that to me
i don't think it points to the bears i
don't see new england moving up
a source said to me this morning they're
not moving up to four
but no if something starts to creep down
a little bit
then you know belichick might pounce on
that a little bit
do you rule out the steelers being
involved in any of this
you know given you know ben's sort of
fragility here
uh yeah i wouldn't and i wouldn't rule
out the saints either i know they've got
a couple
in-house options there that they're
looking at but if
like to me if trey lance were to drift a
little bit
um i could see sean payton saying let's
just let's do it man let's get bold and
aggressive and go up there and go get
them so
yeah there's kind of like those
different layers of teams there's the
teams you know 15
to 20 and then you get to the teams kind
of towards the back end it's a long way
to travel it's going to be very
expensive
for those teams but the good news is
you're picking at the bottom of the
first round you're mike tomlin
you're sean payton you're not going
anywhere you've got time to uh to let
this thing grow and develop here so that
could lead to a bold move
what will happen what should happen at
three
let's start there i think they should
take trey lance
i've been saying that for a long time i
think it allows them to play 11 on 11
uh with incorporating him in the run
game i think kyle with his creativity
i would think that would tap into that i
think that
and look mac jones a good player i
always you know feel like
you're trying to take down mac jones
he's a good player
but i like trey lance's chances of of
narrowing that accuracy gap with max
jones a lot more than
mac jones's chances of narrowing the
athleticism gap with trey lance
so i i think that i think trey's going
to get there he's got some mechanical
things he needs to clean up
um i know he hasn't made a lot of start
stand i know the lower level i i hear i
know all the knocks
i've spent time with this kid i've been
around him i've talked to all the teams
that have interviewed him
he's brilliant he's not like oh he's
football smart he's smart smart
uh and so to me when you have all those
traits and you're highly intelligent
that reminds me of josh allen that
reminds me of patrick mahomes they
didn't have it figured out when they
walked into the nfl
but they had all the ability and they
were incredibly intelligent
okay but you used to be an nfl scout for
a couple of teams yeah let's say you're
with the niners and you're talking to
kyle shanahan
now he's making the he's making the
choice how do you
convince the boss that he's wrong
um i i think you do it in a creative
fashion you want to role play it here
for a second
okay all right hey what's up what's up
dan
uh wait what do you got what are you
last call here
you know i was just thinking about you
know the best advantage we have in our
organization kyle
it's your brain um yeah i mean you're so
smart and so creative
if only there was a quarterback out
there that would allow you to explore
some new areas in your offense
to give us a schematic advantage and
match that with the physical skill sets
man i just i'm trying to rack my brain
to see if i could find somebody that
might just be big and strong and you
know could really grow and develop and
you could take this
offense which is already really good uh
to a whole new place
that would be wow kyle if you could
think of anybody like that
i'm just i'm at a loss i couldn't come
up with anybody yeah but look i'm
looking at mac because mac
is accurate you know he throws people
open he's going to follow my game plan
you know i don't have to worry about him
sort of stretching things he has
more athleticism than people giving
credit for what are the two things i
want to quarterback daniel
you know i want accuracy and you know i
want somebody who's really sharp who's
going to in real time process the
information
oh kyle i i hear you on that and that's
the way it's been and i just i just
would let's let's flash back a little
bit the two times you were standing on
the sidelines in the super bowl there
was one play
you had to lead and your quarterback had
a free rusher come at him and he
couldn't get away from him he took a
sack
you end up out of field goal range you
end up losing a super bowl and then
there was this other super bowl where
this other quarterback
scrambled around for about 10 seconds
and made some unbelievable throw and man
that's you've got five fingers though
two of them would have rings on them
right now
um if you had a guy that could move
around and do those types of things so
let's go try and find that guy uh daniel
it's a little too
soon to bring up the two super bowls
that i lost here
thanks for your input and good luck with
your new team or
when you go to the nfl network it
started off well we started off well
yes it did uh kyle pitts feels like he's
being set up
for failure here like i know he's got
all this talent but i like i don't know
if he's the next vernon davis or not
but like we look at him and we go oh my
god like
he can't miss but guys miss daniel
yeah i i hear you dan but there's
there's some guys where you just kind of
get that feeling and
when quentin nelson was coming out it
was like
i said it at the time he's the best he's
the best blocker like the best run
blocker that i've ever
i've never seen anybody do what he did
in the run game just dominated people
i know it wasn't a sexy position um but
it was like okay if we're gonna say
likely hall of famers he would be the
one you would you would pin it to
because you just don't see it i mean you
watch you watch hundreds of players
every year dan and then every now and
then there's
one guy that just looks different well
my sword said
you know daniel going into the draft he
goes nobody's going to care about this
quentin nelson is the best player in
this draft yeah
and he goes but nobody nobody cares
about an offensive lineman
but you'll be talking about him as a
hall of famer and i remember mentioning
it on the air
like nobody cares about quentin nelson
except for the quarterback who has
quentin nelson blocking for him yeah i
almost want to even say from a tv
standpoint the pick is in
uh it's quentin nelson go to break
[Laughter]
yeah that's a buzz kill um so okay
what should the falcons do at four uh i
again we'll see what happens with the
quarterbacks i would take a quarterback
to me
i think if you feel like you can chase a
championship
for the what's left of matt ryan's
career then take the tight end
but what if tray lance is not there
daniel what if the niners take
look i would prefer trey over field i
would still take justin fields if i were
the falcons because i tell this audience
being a scout like what are we missing
on justin fields
because if we look at everything factor
in everything
yeah there's there's something missing
here
yeah he's incredibly talented dan and i
have four quarterbacks in my top eight
players in the draft so
um to me i think sometimes it's i keep
getting this question what's wrong with
justin
fields what and i'm like it's actually
more kind of what's right with some of
these other guys too
it's not what's wrong with justin fields
justin fields is very gifted
the difference to me like trey lance and
justin fields
is they're touching each other on my
sequence list they're right next to each
other
i gave trey lance the nod because i
thought he was a better decision maker
i thought he played with more more
urgency and and that's
urgency and everything in terms of just
boom boom boom getting through your
reads in terms of making a decision
getting rid of the football not taking
sacks
um just that was the the little
difference there between those two guys
i think justin fields got a chance to be
a you know a pro bowl quarterback
um so if i'm the atlanta falcons and
i've got a quarterback going into his
age 36 season
i don't think we're close to a
championship to me it feels more like a
tear down
than a final missing piece to go get a
super bowl and
it feels like you're in love with trey
lance
if you worked for the jets would you
take trey lands
i that would be a really tough call
i ended up with zach over over trey um
because of i thought he was more
consistent as a thrower and there's some
you get some wow with zach wilson as
well you get a little bit of sizzle with
some of the stuff that he can do
but from the outside not having a chance
to visit with zach like i've met with
trey
i wish i would have had a chance to
spend a lot of time around zach when
you're with a team
i think that can be kind of the deciding
factor in this it's kind of how they
come through
uh that process so i ended up with zach
but man it would uh if you're running a
team that would be the choice for me
those two guys
wow that's interesting i like that jerry
jones said
hey i'm not infatuated with kyle pitts
while
being infatuated with kyle pitts could
dallas do something
you know not crazy but well maybe it is
because that team needs help on defense
but could you see jerry jones doing
something a little goofy
tonight i'm anxious to see if he gets
uh spooked a little bit by the fact that
the eagles and the giants are right
behind him
um and you've got the eagles at 12 who
do need a corner
the cowboys that need the is is the
corner you need the edge rusher but
there's not i don't think there's one
really to take there
um so you're both chasing the same
player i would love to be
um if denver's not taking a quarterback
i had him taking justin fields i had him
just moving up to seven and taking
fields but if they are
happy at quarterback and they want to
roll with what they've got oh my gosh
how fun would that be to play the eagles
and the cowboys against each other no
one they more than likely want the same
player
uh to see if you can get a little extra
for one of those teams to come up
so you're talking about going after a
defensive back i think it would be
certain that would be my guess that's my
guess is that's probably the target for
the cowboys and the eagles
would you trade for jimmy garoppolo
um depending on where you are
in the like the patriots to me and i
don't know what they're going to do i
guess there's some reports out there
saying they might do it
nobody knows what the patriots are going
to do that's a great point um
that one not knowing the inner dynamics
of how his relationship was with josh
mcdaniels and
and the crew there the way jimmy
garoppolo plays provided he could
you know stay healthy which he hasn't
been able to do he it matches the way
the patriots are built i mean they're
offensive line driven they're run game
driven
their defense special teams protect the
football like it's kind of how jimmy
plays um so it makes sense from the
outside but again i don't know how he's
viewed in the building
yeah i just wonder what he's worth i
know they said they want a first round
pick no
no chance you're not kidding no no chin
yeah i think you're looking i i'd be
happy if you got a third round pick
yeah it's not it's not the abi he's the
availability how do you give up a high
pick because he can't stay healthy
yeah yeah it's it's it there's some
fascinating you know plot twist that
could happen because all it takes is you
know
like you go back to mitchell trubisky
you're like nobody saw that no
i think you had him going to cleveland
yeah yeah
there's no way there's no way in the
whole the that's what's so that's why i
love tonight man it's fun
and i i'm part of me was frustrated
because i want to know what san
francisco is going to do
and then i'm like you know what it's
more fun sitting up there on the desk
when they're on the clock and you don't
know what they're gonna do yeah so i
hope i hope it remains a mystery when we
get up to the start of the night
well i want you to react the way we
react because
then you know i i've been involved in an
nba draft before and they said you want
to know the pick when it's in and i said
no
no you know all i want to know is right
before
the commissioner comes out just tell me
who it is so i get my information
that was it but i wanted to react in
real time
and there are times when i'm watching
the draft where i get the feeling that
the host
might know what the pick is before the
pick is because then you'll go
i'm thinking maybe uh
wide receiver or running back and the
pick is in
and they take a wide rece you know and
then you're going um the best the best
the best
and i we have a great group and so i
just remember watching this as a kid so
this is not with nfl network this is
elsewhere but it was they're on the
clock for 10 minutes
they need a receiver it's a receiver
here's this receiver versus that
receiver and then
oh the pick is in would not be surprised
this is offensive line let's go to the
podium
that's where somebody's in your year
going off it's offensive lineman lyman
lyman
uh have fun tonight and uh i'll probably
text you during the show
all right dan see my shirt here real
quick el nino
i mean okay fernando tati's fun to watch
okay so you're on the bandwagon here oh
dan i
i go back to watching kilvio varus buddy
there's no bandwagon i've been riding
this thing for a long time
well i go back to mike ivy oh nice how
about dave drevecki
dave poor dave gervecky
broke his arm yep uh who else
uh freddie norman like i go back to the
early
70s of the padres when they had those
ugly uniforms
it looked like a bad diaper that you
changed
call me dan when you go to an opening
day when there's lynn
nguyen and gwen in the outfield for the
padres
thank you bud see you buddy that's
daniel jeremiah he'll be
on the set tonight with rich eisen kurt
warner
michael irvin probably charles davis i
got a
melissa stark will be doing the
interviews they got a a cast of
thousands fred kendall
another san diego padre